هناك عدد متزايد من
حالات تفشي فيروس كورونا في إسبانيا بعد أن تم رفع
أمر الحبس على الصعيد الوطني الذي
استمر لأكثر من ثلاثة أشهر منذ
حوالي شهر وبدأ الناس في
التحرك في جميع أنحاء البلاد
والالتقاء في المناسبات الاجتماعية منذ ذلك
الحين كان هناك أكثر من  مائة
وخمسون حالة تفشي ، من بين أسوأ الحالات في
المنطقة الشمالية الشرقية من كاتالونيا ، أحدها
يشمل عمال المزارع الموسميين الذين يقطفون
الدراق والكمثرى ويعيشون في أماكن قريبة ،
وآخر في برشلونة ،
وقد طلب مسؤولو المدينة المجاورة هناك من
سكان برشلونة البقاء في المنزل ولكن
هذا ليس إلزاميًا  أبلغت إسبانيا عن أكثر
من 600 حالة إصابة جديدة يوم الجمعة وهو أعلى
رقم يومي منذ أوائل مايو. كانت إسبانيا
واحدة من أكثر البلدان تضررا في
أوروبا حيث يكمن فيروس كورونا مع أكثر
من 28 ألف حالة وفاة وأكثر من 260
ألف حالة وعد المسؤولون
بتتبع المخالطين وعزل سريع للمصابين.
أي حالات جديدة لكن النقاد يقولون إن ذلك
لم يتم تنفيذه بشكل موحد في جميع
أنحاء البلاد  عندما تحاول إسبانيا تجنب
موجة ثانية واسعة النطاق ، أصبح ارتداء
الأقنعة إلزاميًا الآن في الأماكن العامة في جميع
الأوقات في معظم أنحاء إسبانيا
عندما تصل إلى Hosur ، غادر موطنه
فنزويلا للعثور على عمل في بيرو ، كان يأمل
في انتظار الطاولات أو ربما الاختلاط  كوكتيلات
للسائحين ولفترة من الوقت فعل ذلك ، لكن
مع وصول الوباء إلى الخراب بعد
الإغلاق وفقد وظيفته الآن ،
يجمع لويس خوسيه جثث ضحايا كوفات
للحكومة المحلية
ويأخذهم ليتم حرقهم ،
وهو يكسب 500 دولار شهريًا وهو ما خوسيه.
يلتقط مواطنه نيستور أكثر من 20
جثة يوميًا
[موسيقى] هناك
القليل من الوظائف التي تحمل مستوى الخطر الذي
يواجهه هؤلاء الرجال كل يوم ، وهناك القليل من الوقت
للراحة في مقبرة ليماس
القديمة هذه الأيام ،
وهذا هو الوضع الطبيعي الجديد إذا كنت تستطيع تحمل تكاليفها
الحاجز عالي السرعة الذي لا
يستطيع حضوره سوى ثلاثة أفراد من العائلة ، ويستمر لمدة 10
دقائق فقط ، ولا يمكن للآخرين سوى احترام
فضيلة عائلة شخص آخر يستهلكها
الحزن في بلد راكع على ركبتيه ،
وهنا ينتهي بك الأمر إذا لم تستطع المساعدة
موقع دفن دا في صندوق من الورق المقوى في
محرقة الجثث حيث لا يتوقف دخان الموت
أبدًا معظم العمال هنا هم
أيضًا من فنزويلا أورلاندو هو
أحدهم يعمل 12 ساعة في اليوم سبعة
أيام في الأسبوع لدعم أطفاله الأربعة في
المنزل.  لو أن خطيتك هي
عدوك ، أورلاندو هو المسؤول عن
الألبان ، لم يتخيل أبدًا أنه سيرى
الكثير من الموت ،
لقد نسيت أنهم يستطيعون أمريكا شهرًا
بعد الآن الملاريا بحلول حلول الليل ، قام
لويس خوسيه وفريقه بالفعل
بجمع 15 جثة من أحياء ليماس الأكثر
تضررًا ولكن  كان اليوم
بعيدًا عن
الانتهاء ، كان راؤول أوليفاريس يبلغ من العمر 63 عامًا ، وقد
اقتلته الأسرة في ثلاثة أيام ، واستدعت العائلة
سيارة إسعاف لنقله إلى المستشفى
ولم يصل أبدًا ، لذا كان عليهم ببساطة
مشاهدته وهو يموت في الساعة 11 مساءً.  يتلقى الرجال
مكالمة أخيرة من via Mary Landrieu
للمستشفى ، وعليهم جمع 13
جثة أخرى لأن الثلاجة هنا
طعامنا بينما ينتظرون
الأوراق التي يأخذون قضمةهم الأولى
لتناولها في ساعات Monika's him to yarmulke
Nemo mañana Passarella fortune  حسنًا ،
على الرغم من هذه التحديات ، فقد اتخذ خوسيه لويس
شيئًا إيجابيًا من هذه
التجربة ،
غادر هؤلاء الرجال البلاد بحثًا عن
حياة أفضل وما زالوا يأملون في العثور عليها ، قال
المسؤولون الكوبيون يوم الإثنين إنهم سجلوا صفرًا
للمرة الأولى منذ
بداية الوباء.
حالات إصابة جديدة بفيروس كورونا بالإضافة إلى عدم
وجود وفيات قالت السلطات الصحية الكوبية
إنه لا يوجد مرضى في
المستشفى مصابين بفيروس كرونا
في حالة حرجة
قال مسؤولو الصحة الكوبيون إنهم لم
يقضوا تمامًا على فيروس كرونا في هذه
الجزيرة لكنهم يشعرون أن برنامجهم
إغلاق حدود
التعقب الواسع للمخالطين لإلزام كل
مريض وكثير من الأشخاص القريبين منهم
الذهاب إلى المستشفى هنا وكذلك
إلزام الناس بارتداء أقنعة الوجه
في الأماكن العامة وأن كل هذه الإجراءات
قد نجحت وأنهم قد عازمون على
الحد وأنهم في الواقع يعتقدون الآن
أن انتشار هذا الفيروس
تحت السيطرة  لقد مضى أكثر من أسبوعين
منذ أن بدأت معظم أجزاء هذه الجزيرة في
إعادة الافتتاح ، مما يعني أن وسائل
النقل العام قد عادت إلى العمل وذهب إلى العديد من
الشركات ، حتى أن الشواطئ
قد أعيد فتحها ولم نشهد ارتفاعًا في
الحالات ، لذا فإن كل هذا يشير إلى السماح للكوبيين
بالشعور براحة أكبر إلى حد ما  عندما
بدأوا في إعادة فتح هذه الجزيرة ، لكن
بالطبع لم يتحدد بعد
متى ستعيد هذه الجزيرة فتح
المطارات والموانئ ، تم إحضار الحالات الأولى التي وصلت
إلى كوبا من قبل
السياح وبالطبع هذه الجزر على بعد 90 ميلاً
فقط من ولاية فلوريدا  حيث
ينتشر فيروس كورونا خارج نطاق السيطرة
، لا يزال هناك الكثير من القلق من أنه بمجرد أن
تعيد كوبا فتح حدودها ، فقد يؤدي ذلك إلى
ظهور حالات جديدة مسؤولي الصحة الكوبيين
يوم الاثنين  قال ay إنهم
يعتقدون أنه لا تزال هناك بعض
الحالات التي لا تظهر عليها أعراض
ولم يكتشفوها ، لذا فهم لا يخففون
من حذرهم حتى الآن لكنهم يقولون إن
استراتيجيتهم ضد فيروس كورونا في
كوبا تعمل باتريك أوتمان سي إن إن
هافانا